[Music]
on this Saturday night Nowhere to
Run Palestinians flee gaza's largest
hospital as Israel widens its
offensive plus the pain and suffering
after a blast at a un run School
Sheltering
civilians also tonight bombshell
Revelations a new report claims one of
the two Michaels is Seeking a
multi-million doll settlement from
Ottawa he is making some serious
allegations why Michael spavor is
blaming Michael cick for his arrest in
China and the black Battalion they were
proud of what they did they came back
and they were functioning in Oblivion
more than a century later Canada's only
all black unit to serve in the first
world war receives a special
honor global national with foreign
assets
reporting tonight Jeff simple good
evening thank you for joining us Israel
is expanding its ground offensive in the
heart of Gaza and has reportedly ordered
the immediate evacuation of the strip's
largest hospital hundreds have been
forced to flee as Israeli forces
continue searching alifa hospital they
claim a secret Hamas Command Center lies
underneath something Hamas has
repeatedly denied multiple blasts were
reported across the strip today
including a United Nations run School
where hundreds were believed to be
Sheltering Mike Armstrong has our top
story tonight and a warning you may find
the video
disturbing it is an accusation denied by
the Israeli military but of the people
fleeing Gaza City Saturday some were
healthcare workers they say they were
forced out of Aliva hospital by Israeli
Defense Forces given 1 hour to
leave Dr romez radwa says what was
gaza's biggest hospital now has just a
team of nurses and a single surgeon
everyone else he says was forced to
evacuate
alifa now according to the Hamas run
Health Ministry about 500 patients left
at
gunpoint from a high of about, 1500
patients it now holds only
125 people are dead and nobody buries
them says mahad Bei there's no food or
drink and the shooting goes on 24 hours
a day
now the IDF has been inside chifa since
Thursday and says it didn't push anyone
out troops just helped people leave
because they were asked to by the
hospital
administrator that is what we've
coordinated um throughout the day and
we've seen people leaving at the those
that
can now air strikes in the north
continue this is video of the aftermath
of a reported strike Saturday on a un
school being used as a shelter the
Palestinian Health Ministry says at
least 50 people were
killed the Israeli military continues to
tell gazin the south is safer it's also
hitting what it considers military
Targets in the South Health officials
say this strike on a house killed
15 there were two rockets according to
this man in an area he says Israel tells
the world is
safe gazan officials say since the
beginning of this conflict the death
toll is now over 12,000 a number of the
United Nations says is credible but
they're also the injured about
[Music]
30,000 this man says there were about 80
people in a building that was hit in Han
yunes many of them were people who had
left the north now there are new
warnings about that City Israeli
officials are urging civilians to leave
they say Hamas Fighters may now be held
up there and people should move west
something Observer sake could point to
an Israeli ground defensive in that area
area Israeli Prime Minister Saturday
night said his troops will go wherever
they have to to get Hamas Fighters
people in the South he said will
understand that soon
enough Benjamin Netanyahu was also asked
about Hamas leadership outside the Gaza
Strip living in places like Cotter and
Lebanon he said all members of Hamas
even outside Gaza he considers dead men
Jeff Mike Armstrong in Jerusalem thanks
Mike and there are growing fears that
fighting along Israel's border with
Lebanon could spark a wider mid East
conflict Israel's Defense Forces and
Iran backed Hezbollah traded rocket fire
again today according to reports
Israel's latest attack hit an aluminum
Factory 15 kilometers from the border
that's the deepest strike inside Lebanon
since the Hamas
attack the Israeli government is facing
criticism from its own people afraid for
the more than 200 hostages believed to
be held by
Hamas
[Applause]
family members of the missing were
joined by tens of thousands of
protesters as they finished a five-day
March from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem they're
demanding the government do more to
secure the host's release they fear
Israel's Siege is jeopardizing the lives
of their loved
ones turning to other news now and a new
bombshell revelation in the case of the
two Michaels the Canadians detained in
China for nearly 3 years accused of
spying a new report from the globe in
mail citing unnamed sources says Michael
spavor is Seeking a multi-million doll
settlement from Ottawa according to the
report spavor claims he was an unwitting
victim and he blames the Canadian
government and Michael covrig for his
detention a standing ovation for the two
Michaels following their release from
Chinese prisons a couple of years ago
Ottawa claimed they were political pawns
detained following the arrest of a
Chinese Tech executive mungan Joe in
Vancouver
but according to the globe in mail
spavor lawyers are telling a different
story long before his arrest the
entrepreneur had moved to China and was
working to drum up investments in North
Korea okay passort here in 2013 spavor
made headlines when he helped to
facilitate a trip to the hermit Kingdom
for American basketball star Dennis
Rodman that led to spab or's unlikely
friendship with North Korea's reclusive
dictator Kim Jong-un it's alleged that
spavor later recounted his experiences
to fellow Canadian expat Michael cover
over drinks according to the globe
report spavor lawyers alleged that
unbeknownst to him cck then shared that
intelligence with officials in Ottawa
and in Beijing which ultimately led to
spavor arrest it's such a immense relief
to be back in Canada C was working as a
diplomat at the Canadian embassy in
Beijing and in 2017 joined an
independent Global Think Tank the
international crisis group the Fed
federal government says C was not a spy
and has never worked for CIS diplomatic
officers are tasked with collecting
information on security in countries of
strategic importance but they are not
meant to conduct covert operations a
government spokesperson told Global News
perpetuating the notion that either
Michael was involved in Espionage is
only perpetuating a false narrative
under which they were detained by
China joining us now from Montreal is G
sjac who was Canada's former ambassador
to China between 2012 and 2016 uh Mr St
Jo thank you so much for joining us nice
to see you uh let's start first with
with your reaction to the revelations
we've learned today well I knew that
there were ongoing negotiations uh uh
taking place in Ottawa I know that uh
those with Michael cck were settled some
time ago I didn't know exactly where uh
the negotiations were uh with Mr sper
but of
course is making uh some serious
allegations and I must say that based on
my experience um uh you know I don't
think it's the the full story H what do
you mean by that well I think that the
Mr sper was watched by the the Chinese
security people and the reason for this
is that China considers North Korea as
its uh backyard and here is a foreigner
a Canadian who has a very close access
to the North Korean leader Kim jongan
something that no Chinese has and and
for that uh there was a bit of jealousy
or concern uh of how influential Mr sper
could be and from my perspective I think
this is the main reason why uh he was
arrested by the Chinese as noted Mr C
worked at the embassy there at around
the same time as your tenure was Mr C A
cisus
agent no no not at all in fact he was a
a good political officer and there is an
important distinction with spying work
and uh uh political reporting work uh
diplomats that are assigned to political
sections abroad are charged with doing
political reporting of course in a
country like China it's very difficult
to have access to good information
because it's so opaque and Michael being
able to travel around uh you know I'm
sure that the the anyone at the embassy
would have been interested to to hear
what he had learned during his trips and
Michael Ki was very open about this you
know that this was not done in in secret
gjac for Canada's former ambassador to
China thank you so much for your time
really appreciate it
thank you the Fallout continues from a
global news investigation with
allegations that Canada has become a
safe haven for hundreds of people
connected to the Iranian regime they're
accused of threatening Canadians
prompting calls for the federal
government to respond Mercedes Stevenson
joins me now from the annual Global
Security Summit in Halifax hi Mercedes
so what's been the reaction there to how
Canada is handling this threat well Jeff
folks here are concerned about the
Iranian regime and it's influence all
around the world from Canada to the
United States to the UK there are
worries that Iran is not just using
proxies in places like the Middle East
through Hamas and Hezbollah but that
they are also involved in trying to
intimidate threaten potentially even
kidnap or kill Canadian American and UK
citizens I sat down with Massie alinad
she's a very prominent human rights
expert from Iran who previously spoke to
Global News and I asked her about the
prime minister's response to our
reporting where he said that essentially
the government is doing all they can to
try to deal with Iran and will continue
to try to do so she had a pretty strong
message for prime minister Justin
Trudeau you know these are cliche and
empty word and prime minister trudo I
want to use this camera and talk to you
directly don't be scared of me and women
like you know you and critical
journalists and Iranian Canadians in
Canada we love Canada we love peace and
security and democracy we love Canada to
be a
shelter for you know decent people and
you're putting the lives of Canadians in
danger so I want to meet you that's all
I can say because otherwise he's going
to come up with a lot of empty words
saying that we stand with the people of
Iran no please sit down and make
decisions how to protect uh human rights
how to protect democracy in Canada
that's very
important
some uh Iranian regime critics have
suggested Jeff that Canada needs to
criminalize the irgc right now there are
rules to prevent those officials from
entering Canada but it is not listed as
a terror entity that's one of the things
that many Iranian expats say they'd like
to see happen Mercedes Stevenson in
Halifax tonight
thanks and you can hear more about this
tomorrow morning on the west block
that's right here on
global national security officials are
investigating reports of BC companies
drone detection technology was sold to
Russia in violation of sanctions
according to Ukrainian and Russian media
reports the equipment from
vancouver-based skyscope Technologies
was recently acquired by a Moscow
University the anti-drone system can
detect hundreds of different types of
drones at long distances skyscope
Technologies denies violating
sanctions paying the mortgage coming up
some much needed good news for Canadian
homeowners
3 2
1 spacex's Starship roared into the sky
this morning before it was intentionally
destroyed mid-flight the nearly 400ft
rocket ran into trouble minutes after
takeoff one of its boosters exploded
over the Gulf of Mexico Mission Control
lost contact moments later saying the
Rockets onboard system destroyed the
vehicle this was the starship's second
test launch its April attempt also ended
in
Failure space X's owner Elon Musk also
owns X formerly Twitter of course and
the billionaire is now facing backlash
for supporting an anti-semitic post
several Major Brands including apple and
Disney are now pausing ads on his social
media platform after a report from a
media Watchdog Group found ads next to
tweets praising Hitler and the Nazis
musk is now threatening to Sue that
group along with all those who colluded
in what must says is a fraudulent attack
on the
company well if you're one of the
millions of Canadians feeling the pain
from high interest rates some economists
believe relief could be on the way
5-year fixed rate mortgages are already
beginning to dip slightly with borrowing
costs expected to fall further in the
coming years promising news for some but
for those with mortgages up for Renewal
that relief may not come soon enough
Heather urick West
explains for $1.4 million you could be
the next owner of this downtown
Vancouver condo a deal as the city's
normally overheated housing market
starts to cool obviously everyone's
aware that the interest rates have
completely impacted the market it's
starting to increase now uh but it was
definitely the last 3 months have been a
little bit on the slower side in
comparison to previous years it's not
just clients looking to sell the soaring
interest rates have katenzaro
re-evaluating her own Investments too
she had been renting out a revenue
property in Calgary but the costs were
just too high so as an investor
personally uh I ended up selling my
property in in Calgary just recently
just a few months ago mortgage rates for
Canadians uh who are trying to pay off
their house have climbed dramatically
over the last year and a half anyone
with a variable rate mortgage knows this
pain all too well but those with locked
in mortgages will come to know it soon
in 2020 1 a 5-year fixed rate could be
as low as
1.4% today even a discounted rate is
well over five Canadian households are
paying uh an additional $65 billion a
year already from higher interest rates
and that total will probably grow as
more Canadians have their mortgages
renewed the interest rate hikes have
caused housing costs including rents to
soar giving Canadians less money to
spend and fuel inflation enough that a
growing number of economists now believe
we've seen High mortgage rates reach
their Peak and over the next few years
some relief is on the way but we're not
going to go back down to levels that we
saw early in the pandemic boom and
Canadians probably gota H probably got
to get comfortable with normal mortgage
rates being something around like let's
say three and a half or 4% numbers that
may put home ownership Out Of Reach for
some the days of borrowing debt Dirt
Cheap behind us Heather urex West Global
News
Calgary Argentina at a Crossroads still
ahead the divisive presidential election
with high stakes for the country's
economy welcome back Argentina is
preparing to head to the polls in what
looks like a close election to decide
the country's next president their two
choices a controversial far-right
libertarian
and the country's Finance Minister as
Mike Dr reports whoever wins will need
to sort out an economy on the
brink Argentina has found itself out of
political Crossroads and it couldn't be
more contentious or
volatile it's incredible that there is
no Freedom screamed this supporter of
Javier Malay the former TV host turned
farri right libertarian who has
galvanized his supporters with
props using a chainsaw to symbolize the
cuts he's going to make to government
while working his supporters into a
frenzy at his Rock star-like
rallies Long Live Freedom damn it has
become his populous catchphrase which
pushed him to second place in last
month's first round of voting surprising
many political
pundits and what a contrast he is from
his
opponent Sergio Massa the established
Centrist politician who won the first
round of voting but as Minister of
Finance Finance he's seen inflation rise
almost 150% on his watch sending 4 in 10
argentinians under the poverty line the
polls show the election is now too close
to call and the choice for some isn't a
choice at
all this man says he's not voting
neither of them he says represents the
interests I have for the future of the
country what seems certain is that tough
times are ahead for a country that's
been edging towards a financial
catastrophe for years economists see no
other way out than strict austerity
measures which could negatively impact
other South American countries and
argentinians will have to decide who
they trust more to guide them through it
the status quo in Massa or the chainsaw
wielding
Malay a tough choice the country can't
afford to get wrong Mike trite Global
News a Taylor Swift fan has died after
collapsing during sweltering conditions
at a concert in Rio Aro on Friday the
23-year-old's cause of death is not
known but Reports say fans were not
allowed to take water inside the open
air Stadium despite a record-breaking
Heatwave in a handwritten note on
Instagram Swift says she's devastated
calling the victim far too
young honoring the black Battalion next
paying tribute to Canada's only all
black unit of the first World
[Music]
War
Canada's only all black unit to serve
during the first world war faced much
Prejudice throughout the conflict well
now more than a century later Canada's
defense minister has announced a new
initiative to honor the black Battalion
Megan King has the
details this is a significant moment
that some of us never expect to ever see
a Monumental day in the history and
Legacy of the number two construction
Battalion remembering the brave men who
had to fight for their right to serve
Canadians black
Canadians over a century ago wanted to
serve were quite prepared to lay down
their lives for their country and and
when they Ste forward to serve they were
turned away and and and it's important
for us to remember why they were turned
away they were proud of what they did
they came back and they were functioning
in Oblivion they weren't herble they
were un celebrated Blair announcing
$2.25 million in funding towards
educating the public on the history
behind the Battalion and honoring its
memory today's announcement speaks to
their perseverance and it also speaks to
the important aspect of us not
forgetting their legacy there's still a
fear fear part of this country and
internationally who never heard of
number two construction Battalion so the
more we can do these things the more
people know about it in addition to the
funding the black Cultural Center was
presented with the first number two
construction Battalion Camp flag for
commemoration fact that you know this
Battalion served and never had uh an
identification Camp flag and the fact
that that right uh that wrong has been
been Rewritten and today we have
something that we can be proud of as a
symbol of those brave men this event
follows a formal apology to the
descendants of Battalion members by
prime minister Justin Trudeau back in
July 2022 at which point he acknowledged
the systemic anti-black racism the
battalion's 600 members faced before
during and long after the war all
Canadians deserve to know the truth of
our history we need to learn from that
truth so that we can build a more
inclusive country for the Next
Generation Megan King Global News
Cherrybrook Nova
Scotia and that is global national for
this Saturday night I'm Jeff simple
tonight's your Canada is the Thompson
river near spences Bridge BC we love
seeing your Canada so please keep
emailing your photos to viewers at
global.com thanks for watching hope
you'll join us again here tomorrow have
a great
[Music]
night